hallo hier ist der Name Hase und ich
habe eine Frage an Simon Desue wie
findet deine Familie deine Videos finden
Sie die peinlich oder mögen solange
Videos oder sind ihnen deine Videos egal
erst ob ich echt erstaunt was man alles
so basteln kann aus Papier ist cool
wie finde meine Familie meine Videos die
haben kein Problem damit ich habe die
natürlich nie meine Videos gezeigt die
kam selber drauf sie mögen sie hoffe ich
mal haben sie gesagt wer weiß dass sie
mich anlügen nee ähm sie mögen sie
eigentlich vom Ding hier mir gefällt es
auch dass sie sie mögen
aus meinem Bruder der den habe ich die
wirklich gezeigt die habe ich niemals
Videos gezeigt aber ich weiß dass er sie
kennt wenn du sie wenn du mich jetzt
siehst Bruder ich weiß du kennst meine
Videos